Brian Urlacher is here the Bears
hall-of-famer busy weekend Canton Ohio
look at mr. Hall of Famer Joneses on the
program how do they feel this weekend it
was overwhelming it was just crazy you
know you go from one thing to the next
that you get there and they have your
whole schedule timed out for you trying
to take it out of land but I just kept
feeling I was rushed from one thing to
the next but it was man the Hall of Fame
luncheon on Friday unbelievable to
submit all those guys listen to him talk
we can't talk because we're rookies so
we just listen but it was it was cool
wait you're not allowed to talk it's
only the veterans of the Hall of Fame
allowed to talk at the luncheon next
year if we go back I'll be able to talk
but this year it was veterans only who
did you meet where you went I'm actually
listening to this person talk to me
every time I see Joe Namath I'm like wow
that's so nameís not Mel Blount
is one of the biggest like he's probably
64 65 you play corner I just can't he
was saying next for Jill Green I was
like yeah and he's hauled in Joe green
yes inside corner just you know you see
these guys and the errors are different
I know but man some of these guys are
just it's amazing to see them could you
have played safety in the NFL if you
wanted to probably cried I said I think
I'd have been okay I would have to lose
50 I think my rookie year I had to lose
some weight so I was a little bit faster
but much better suited for linebacker in
my opinion all right your speech how
long did it take who held so it took me
so I start jotting stuff down on the way
home after we found out that we were
getting inducted and then as pilot for
three months and then the last month I
started getting answers God named art so
chose to help me with it I wrote
everything was in there was my context
but also help me with the presentation
and I did talk a little faster at some
points but that's just me I can't help
it man I get excited guys talk fast
when you got to the kids I didn't think
you were gonna make it through oh my
gosh I got to my mom I was you know that
was tough but yeah the kids the prompter
was right next to them
so I wasn't looking right at them guys
visor item on a lot I was looking right
beside them and it because if I'm
looking at my audience and I've been
like a little baby up there but your mom
to had to be tough I mean that that
that's you know Alisha kids your kids
are there but when you're talking about
mom ma'am and I'll give you credit cuz
you know everybody's watching and you're
like I gotta get I gotta get through it
your mom was always there James she was
unbelievable obviously you heard what I
said okay
you know I rehearsed the speech quite a
few times so I gone through that part
because you can't account for is the
emotions are still when you're up there
and all the people watching on my whole
family was sitting right in front of me
they're literally 15 funny I'm looking
at everybody so I just couldn't take
that into consideration when I was out
there by I did a good job of pausing and
taking a breath when I felt that coming
on and just waiting you're letting it
pass and it feels in that jacket on
unbelievable now we got in the mail and
I put it on for about 10 seconds to make
sure sit took it off real fast because I
want to be special I wanted to be
special so I took it off her cool can
send it back to them but man it's uh it
was unbelievable to kind of you know and
I didn't really feel like I was in until
after I was done with my speech I was
like alright now you made it now you can
relax was like a huge release off of me
once I was done with my speech and also
cool inside pocket of the jacket and
it's got your number you know the number
that you're going into the Hall of Fame
the number of members describe what that
looks like that little patch that they
have on the inside part of the jacket
pocket of my jacket
it says Brian Urlacher Hall of Fame
class 2018 number 318 that's my home
number cemented in an eighteenth person
to be inducted into the Pro Football
Hall of Fame it's cool man the jackets
kind of like I like that because it's
hot as hell out there
he's on Saturday oh my gosh I didn't but
in case I look like a fool in shade so I
didn't take shades but it was bright it
was hot and in unison
some we're gonna put a good spot on the
stage where the Sun kind of went down
and we cut a bunch of shade which member
of your class looks like they could
still play Terrell Owens
Brian Dawkins Randy looks the same to me
all the time I always liked boys w7o 0-4
three you know that's how I've always
felt about Randy but you look at be doc
and he's just put together and you know
tiel's always looks like you can play
have any problem with tio not selling no
I wish he would have been there to get
his due
you know so he can be the center of
attention you know you get those 15 20
minutes up there where it's just all
about you say what you want to you know
everyone's focused on you that's your
one chance to be selfish if you want to
be you know is there one time where to
hold everyone's just pay attention to
you so I got no problem doing what he
did you know I wish you became and been
inducted with the wrestlers but these
guys reasons do you miss on field or off
the field all off the field for sure we
had a blast we have to I think the best
locker room of all time we did so much
super stuff in there two games we played
the the stupid stuff we made up just to
pass the time in between meetings and we
had a bunch of your characters in our
locker room give me an idea of some
stupid stuff now that you're not now
that you're a Hall of Famer
you're allowed to say okay well you play
tape make a table and play baseball I
would strike Lance out like 40 times a
week we play dodgeball Saturday mornings
offense versus defense we go through our
walkthrough then we go just tear up so I
feel so bad for our locker our equipment
guys because we just taught a locker
room the shreds
we would put the laundry baskets in the
middle first like the line you can cross
play dodgeball for half an hour we had
this stupid game where we'd get a
dodgeball and we'd shoot it across the
locker room on yet to hit the exact part
of the rail across rooms to earn a point
we made them a there's some gambling
gonna say I'm not sure another game
where we fill the ball into the trash
can from 30 feet away possible Lakers
may on that as well
just stupid games of soccer game you
broke every light in a locker room just
the time
you gotta get a fast time somehow did
Cutler was he part of dodgeball
oh yeah hit me in the chest one day hard
I was smart guy took my shirt off
because it was hot and I think there was
like three or four of us left on each
side and j-just you rub me right in the
chest I had a big circle of my chest
have you seen have you seen very
Cavallari have you seen Cutler's reality
show oh my god you like I don't know
what you dealt with with Cutler but I
have greater appreciation for how he is
he does he doesn't give a damn he
doesn't want to do anything oh my god I
feel bad for his wife because well he
just wants to drain her we're really
loose Oh same as a bootlegger
I mean to do it home good for you you
know that's a win right there he'll
watch you know videos of like a deer
blind like you like you could do a live
look in on YouTube he just sits around
and doesn't know anything
I mean it's fascinating it doesn't look
like he's working out but uh I'm not
saying it shows stupid but I haven't
caught that one yet how's retirement
treating you I'm having a great time and
I feel like now that school started
again for the kids so my son has flag
football practice from 245 to for travel
factors from six to eight and then the
weekends are just about busy RIA my
daughter's an ostrich right national
star basketball and apply of two months
and my oldest doesn't play any sports
users like a super straight a honor
student smart girl she only goes after
day and night cuz she's a senior so you
know but life still revolves around them
I get up and do school thing and then I
go work out ride my bike trying to pass
the time there's no day but no like you
get that feeling sometimes your body
will tell you it's a certain time of the
year certainly when you play football
you know are you gonna have that where
it's like tap our bodies there's my body
my body just keep doing what you're
doing
Oh join us off right now it doesn't want
to be a three-hitter or hit anybody else
so it's uh it's time to keep doing what
you're doing if you could pop one more
gun one more time who would do more yeah
you got 111 yeah you can hit anybody you
know I got ran over a really bad by
Jerome Bettis one time and I mean I
think his shoe leather imprint in my
chest as he ran over me so I'd like to
get a pop on him but I don't know if
it'd be a good plan just like a solid
hit where maybe I didn't go backwards
and even if I just stood him up I'd like
to hit him because we got I'm talking
about there's a picture of it I've seen
a few times I don't people ask me why
and I refuse to sign it that I'm just
I'm flying backwards and he's about to
score so I like to get a good pop on
Jerome if that's even possible to get
wrong does that come up in conversation
at the Hall of Fame weekend no every
time I see Jerome no I are you so bad
story still see him well I think you're
home a lot not just the Hall of Fame I
see in a lot of functions you know a lot
of guys do a lot of golf terms as I say
I'm not those all the time is this is
this a game that was in the snow it was
it was actual five we had one like I
think eight straight games or something
like that and they they had to run the
rest of their games to get in the
playoffs they beat us won the rest of
their games and it was it's great to
catch up with it Congrats what did the
kids think of how your bust look oh you
know what
the suits to see me was hair their look
kind of different so I was like whoa man
the whole family used to the hair now so
when I see the bust ball but I tell
people I think people remember me as a
football player so they thought it was
good you know they were kind of there
when the guy came over - well then came
over to our to do the bus so they
started kind of the process of it no one
saw the end result until Saturday night
but we saw the process happening and I
was weird that you volunteered to pose
naked just when they were doing your
bust which I found that's kind of
strange Bryant Congrats good to catch up
with you very proud of you Thank You
Ronnie for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]